d'ici demain ces tuyaux métalliques
d'une longueur de près d'un kilomètre et
demi disparaîtront du décor de l'île
d'orléans avec l'aide d'une dizaine de
grues
ils seront graduellement être produit
dans un tunnel sous fluvial
actuellement les tables sont déposés
directement au fond de l'eau capio
métallique de 6 pouces de diamètre qui
ont été introduits dans notre forage qui
n'a le rock
ce forage là une distance de 1441 mis
sous le lit du fleuve qui parle d' ici à
l'île d'orléans à saint-pierre et qui se
termine à la regardiez sur la rive nord
l'enfouissement des conduits dans
lesquelles seront par la suite insérer
les câbles est une autre étape du vaste
chantier pour moderniser l'alimentation
en électricité de l'île d'orléans
ces câbles sont rendus afin durée de vie
utile
donc il fallait les remplacer la beauté
de ce projet là c'est tout est
entièrement souterrain ya pas un impact
dame milieu ils vont une dalle on pense
que dure une ville plus intéressante ce
type de travail l'opus qui étant donné
que des tuyaux qui sont pendants
allocution dans un forage
une fois que les câbles les câbles
électriques auront atteint leur faim
durée de vie il va être possible de les
retirer et de réenfiler d'autres câbles
tandis qu'une solution avec une carte
déposé sur le lit du fleuve pour les
retirer et re a débuté le travail
les nouveaux câbles auront la même durée
de vie que ceux actuellement en place
soit entre 25 et 50 ans la mise en
service des nouvelles installations dont
le coût atteint 20 millions de dollars
est prévue en décembre
ici nicole germain radio-canada saint
pierre